insomma il famoso back in episodio di
apple gaiba ragazzi allora siamo sussisa
che era un botto che non la facevano è
vero parte sempre questa ogni volta
inizia un episodio di paul guys che è la
mappa più odiosa di tutte quante forse
anche vivo all mountain e la cosa mi fa
girare giustamente le balle e che se tu
giochi
stavo dicendo se tu giochi up all night
la prima partita deve essere abbastanza
tranquilla insomma tranquilla senza
rotture di palle deve essere la prima
partita quindi si son non è proprio la
più indicata visto che per finirla de
niente insomma ripassare un po la bibbia
la musica e canti della bibbia perché
cosa che faremo noi in questo video non
adesso perché mediamente piano c'è
quanto lo prendo che già è un traguardo
pazzesco se questi qua si trovi lo dt
non si butta un po di sua stessa 30
farlo magari riesco anche a raggiungere
il prossimo dovrebbe essere ok
oddio giustizialista perché mi ha fatto
salire come volta salita sopra questo
box
pazzesco va beh ogni tanto qualcuno se
ne esce con delle cagate non so neanche
come dicevo insiste o ragazzi importante
rimanere prime all'inizio perché almeno
voi non avete concorrenza perché più
gente c'è più difficile campo boe viola
ma fire and next up e spera longines di
come sempre del craxi
mammamia meraviglioso almeno rimaniamo
qui in 30 laghi crash ragazzi è la più
se come credo che tra se serio tra tutte
l'inizio più stupido perché non ci vuole
niente in che il trace basta andare 3 e
tempismo con le porte ma mamma mia
ragazza non sapete fare sa mai che
cresce veramente stupido vamonos reni e
anche abbastanza rapida john l
[Applauso]
perfetto buono ex crumble è una di
quelle che odio di più però facciamo ex
crumble non comando io
via via via va beh ma neanche uno romano
insieme noi qualche banca toglietevi fa
niente di nuovo bravi bravi li difendo
vivendo togli spesso li difendo luogo
difendo un luogo faccio io faccio io con
niente vi sto dicendo ragazzi all inizio
non punto più a loro d'oro perché
purtroppo è talmente pieno di gente va
solo lì che non so quanto serva era da
quelli a sport un nuovo normale
torno e difendo come sto facendo adesso
sisti pezzenti provano ancora mola no
non è vero l'acqua ha fatto oddio oddio
tutti sotto la mappa ma succede cosa
suggella aiuto se gricia dalla mappa
potuto nuovo giallo la cosa ma cosa
avete non so se avete visto del successo
ve lo spiego è schizzato fuori loro
giallo non si sa come alla fine quindi
alla fine abbiamo perso cinque punti
nonostante questo abbiamo vinto meno
male va dai ragazzi allora rimaniamo in
pochi quindi non è neanche male speriamo
magari una finale direttamente col monte
comunque ragazzi io vorrei dire una roba
secondo me jean show down che è una
finale esce veramente troppo poco quale
i ragazzi l'ultima volta avete visto
jean showdown non in live o non esce mai
su playstation ragazzi oppure non è
possibile dunque va bene fatevi
concedere un attimo era meglio se
parlavo porca vacca guarda chi sta
vincendo
guarda che se vince quello ok è caduto è
caduto è caduto anche adottate volta
attenzione a pensare che questa buona ma
attenzione questa buona che questa è
buona
ti prego non chiedere qua perfetto non
ragazzi non ci credo nella merito
mela merito me lo merito tantissimo
perché c'era quel pezzetto vuole una
foto ci godo le ragazze per oggi abbiamo
già dato fortunatamente perché è strano
perché in genere la prima di
riscaldamento non la vinco quasi mai
quando vinco la prima in genere vico
anche la seconda che l'ho detto perfetto
possiamo morire
ok gli zii e mais anche qua giampiero
secondo me poi tagliare abbastanza ok
non mi vado nel muro per ragazzi attenti
sempre quando vi scontrate contro quel
muro perché ogni tanto si vaga animali
incastrati fissi
meno male pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa
burroughs nextup il spero se jeans ed
metà squadra viene tagliata ma non lo
voglio fare e invece proprio jeans o io
lo dico sempre quando faccio jeans che
poi la perdo mai normale ragazzi perché
c'è il 5 height con jeans ei ragazzi
cioè 50 per cento in italia
eliminati perché non dipende da voi
dipende la nostra squadra
perché se fate cag.are se la rottura fa
cagare voi potete essere di fenomeni
potete essere chiuse in volto in folk
guys non cambia niente perché se la
vostra squadra fa cagare voi perdete
uguale no ragazzi mi seguono tutti sta
votando solo me e dai gay sono caduto
fate schifo
e vabbè mi chiami ti sei mangiato
madonna che mi ha fatto cadere uno è
rimasto dei ragazzi eccolo eccolo
no non è vero che meno male meno male
giampiero ragazzi sarebbe jump su dow
solo che non è già show down è un
minigioco nel mezzo
credo sia la penultima perché dopo
questa qua d'altro tra l'altro non sono
neanche troppo forti club perché non la
faccio mai mai anche in jobso da faccio
abbastanza cagare
perché non la faccio mai quindi è anche
vero che come non la faccio spesso io
non la fanno spesso neanche gli altri
però boh non so quanto fidarmi di questa
cosa cosa ha detto già citato dai
ragazzi basta saltare sulla teoricamente
non dovrebbe essere complicatissimo però
mi è capitato alle volte di morire
perché effettivamente quando rimane
vicino al pistone in mezzo alle volte il
tuo personaggio inizia a sheikh e rarsi
il cervello è quindi cade e non è vera
amica mi ha beccato ragazzi con la quale
di tavoli cadere tantissimo perché aveva
beccato ragazzi ve lo dico meritavo
licari certo punto ero più fuori che
dentro non so come ho fatto a rimanere
in piedi quanti rimasti 9 noi rimasti
buono come 10 no erano nove eliminati
sono stupido io va bene erano nove
eliminati non noi rimasti va bene noi
scusate soren i sorry ma volevo equa
effettivamente ci può anche stare col
monte ma dai ma che coincidenza ma che
strano non me lo aspettavo però
teoricamente non porto primo quindi se
non parto primo già è più difficile
vediamo secondo me è una seconda
vittoria potrebbe anche starci
sarebbe veramente incredibile che
vincola pre ogni volta il visto di co2
volte ogni tanto faccio un riscaldamento
iniziale però attenzione
mica si no buono buonissimo
non è vero non è vero sono un caduto
perché sono stupido magari cadono tutti
era che non è detto tensione uno è
caduto
oddio oddio oddio no ma non potevo
vincere ragazzi perché non ho troppo
avanti
se ancora non fosse andata su invece che
invece che scendere piano non so se si
dice italiano questa cosa l'ho detto ma
fa niente poteva ancora vincere perché
tempo che tornava giulio mi ero
allineato agli altri potevo saltare che
sfiga comunque ragazzi ogni volta almeno
in finale ci arrivo teoricamente io
punto sempre alle doppie vittorie però
vabbè adesso magari facciamo da briganti
miei vincono regista però dipende
signori adesso la foga e si oggi spero
vi sia piaciuto parte per il pezzettino
finale mannaggia il cacchio mischiate al
canale tasto mi piace lasciate un
commento qui sotto che vivendo sempre
spento mi fa piacere un commento magari
di sponda anche nel ci vediamo domani
con passione al rialzo
[Musica]